real sad situation that happened to him
did you guys see each other in in jail
at all uh we were in the same place with
different floors so but I heard he was
there I was trying to send a kite to him
and yeah you know but you know should
you be moving around so I was like
it I'm around see him in
reception or something but like for you
like hearing about that in jail like I'm
sure it's it's got to be tough right
hell yeah that was crazy I'm like
man I heard about that right
somebody come and tell me they're like
oh yeah that's some you're like
oh no I'm like bro like I get on the
phone I call I call my boy and he first
thing he says is like bro I was like I
just knew when he said bro I was like
damn I was like what you mean like he
alive though like no I was like man that
that it didn't feel real to me
because you found me was in the studio
like a week before we both turned
ourselves in because he turned himself
in like a week or two before me right
there chilling chopping he was just
telling me he had a lot on his mind too
he's just like you know telling me
who's making music and then I hugged
them he's like all right then I'm gonna
say I'll probably see you in there the
last time I seen him